you can tell we are getting very close to
an election because a lot of the audience
questions coming in relate to the either the
democratic primary or the eventual general
election in November of 2020.
So let's dig right into it.
First question.
Hey, David is the [inaudible] [inaudible]
strategy to split the democratic primary vote
as much as possible to force a brokered convention
and let super delegates decide on the second
ballot.
So let's, we first have to explain this entire
thing.
So you might remember back in 2016 as the
primaries were going on, you would see these
estimates of how many delegates each candidate
had.
And very often you would see, for example,
Hillary Clinton and Bernie Sanders with like
the same number or close to the same number
of delegates on the basis of polling and thus
expected voting in the primary States.
But then you would see another, which says
plus super delegates and Hillary had like
all the superdelegates and then it would seem
as though Bernie simply had no chance whatsoever
of securing the nomination.
Even if you ran the table in the primaries
from that point forward.
And this is one of the ways in which people
accurately said the DNC was set up to deny
Bernie the nomination in 2016 and to help
Hillary Clinton, which is that even before
any ballots were cast in primaries by voters,
super delegates were already known and expected
to be supporting mostly Hillary Clinton over
Bernie Sanders.
So one of the things that the DNC did since
the last primary in order to at least appear
as though they're trying to make the primary
more democratic, as they said, super delegates
will not vote on the first ballot at the convention.
So before the way it worked is you would have
all the primaries leading up to the democratic
national convention.
The primaries would lead to delegates being
sent to the DNC.
The superdelegates would be there and they
would say, let's now vote, and the delegates
would vote based on how their state primary
went, and then the superdelegates would vote.
You add them all up and then somebody, the
nominee maybe or not you go to a second round
with the DNC, decided to do, as they said
in 2020 superdelegates will not vote on the
first round.
Therefore, if a candidate has enough support
in the first round of voting, based solely
on the delegates from the primaries, the superdelegates
won't even get involved.
But if after the first round of voting there
is not a nominee on the basis of the rules,
then we do a second round and the super delegates
are then allowed to participate.
So if one strategy was we need to appear as
though we are putting our thumb on the scales
less than in 2016 but we still want the opportunity
to do that.
You would say, all right, let's get rid of
superdelegate voting in round one, push superdelegate
voting to round two but let's try to make
it so that we get to that second round, make
it so that there is not a candidate selected
in round one of voting at the DNC.
And one way to do that is indeed to split
the vote, but it's actually a two tiered strategy.
The strategy you're talking about of splitting
the vote in order to get super delegates in
a position to decide on the second ballot.
There's a prior strategy to that, which is
let's just reinforce the establishment so
that Joe Biden or increasingly Pete Buddha
judge a win.
And I actually was on TV last week talking
about this on the rising on rising the Hill,
the Hills rising, the show with crystal ball
and cigar and jetty.
And I explained that even if it's not a carefully
crafted strategy, if the DNC is worried about
Biden because they see that he looks slow
during the debate, during the debates, they
see that he's not making a lot of sense on
some issues that every debate he drops in
polling the debate being more publicly visible
is worse for Biden.
If they're worried about that, they can say
who's a good alternative.
It's not Bernie.
Uh, it's not Warren, it's Buddha, judge Buddha
judges the other establishment candidate that
we could get behind by supporting Pete Buddha
judge by giving him more airtime, uh, speaking
time during the MSNBC debate for example,
they are pulling more people into the universe
of centrism.
And if in the end those voters say, you know
what, I don't actually want to vote for Buddha
judge cause he's not experienced enough.
It's a very natural transition to instead
go and vote for Joe Biden.
And so the initial strategy is to basically
default this thing to Joe Biden, but with
the understanding that Biden's having some
problems start supporting Buddha judge just
to get more people thinking centrist rather
than leftist like Warren or Bernie and hopefully
they will just straight out win the nomination
in the first ballot on the basis of primary
results.
Of course, if it doesn't happen, the strategy
of splitting the vote is an effective one
to try to eventually let superdelegates decide
on round two in the democratic national convention.
So they're doing it all.
It's a different strategy than in 2016 because
the rules have changed, but certainly don't
be confused for a second.
The establishment knows who they want and
knows who they don't want and there are multiple
strategies happening at the same time to try
to make that a reality.